bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur
téléphiles soixante dix huit pour le 7-8
chaque soir du lundi au jeudi une heure
pour faire le point sur l'actualité du
département une heure en direct à 18h et
pour débuter la semaine nous allons
revenir sur cette manif pour tous une
mobilisation et après dans un instant
nous entendrons béatrice bourges elle
est porte parole du collectif pour
l'enfant également porte parole de la
manif pour tous est elle était hier dans
les rues parisiennes elle se prononce
contre le projet de loi vous entendrez
également aurore bergé c'est d'une
responsable ump dans les yvelines elle a
beaucoup fait parler d'elle ce week end
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux pour
avoir publié sur le site internet du
nouvel obs une chronique un billet où
elle se dit tout simplement favorable à
ce mariage pour tous pour l'instant
voici les principaux titres les sujets à
découvrir ce soir
la neige fait son retour alerte orange
dans le département à compter de ce
lundi soir 19h et jusqu'à 4 heures du
matin ce mardi les chutes de neige
seront soutenus et durable
la manifestation contre le mariage pour
tous la manif pour tous a également
mobilisé dans le département est des
départs étaient organisées depuis la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines
pouvoir certains c'était leur première
mobilisation et pour les responsables
locaux plus de 800 saint quentinois
seraient descendus dans la rue 4 à 0
défaite sévère pour le petit poucet le
fbi en cours qui affrontait ce dimanche
l'ogre à aj auxerre en coupe gambardella
une défaite toutefois logique mais un
beau souvenir pour le club qui
atteignait pour la première fois les 64e
de finale dans cette compétition
autre compétition de tir au pistolet
cette fois ci à voisins le bretonneux
200 tireurs pour ce championnat régional
de tir à la carabine à 10 m dont pauline
laurent une versaillaise inscrits au
club de voisins elle a gagné son ticket
pour les futurs championnats de france
virgin megastore est donc placée en
redressement judiciaire ainsi on a
décidé ce lundi le tribunal de commerce
de paris un redressement judiciaire
assorti d'une période d'observation de
quatre mois
un sursis pour les salariés car si le
tribunal avait choisi est la mise en
liquidation judiciaire cela aurait
signifié tout simplement la mort de
l'entreprise
virgin compte 26 magasins en france dont
le seul délit
est situé à montigny le bretonneux ce
dernier emploie à lui seul une trentaine
de salariés on passe à présent au fait
du jour est le bras de fer qui se
poursuit entre partisans et opposants au
mariage pour tous une forte mobilisation
et après l'elysée a annoncé qu'il ne
céderait pas le texte sur le mariage
pour tous sera bien présenté au
parlement le 29 janvier ce malgré la
mobilisation dans les rues parisiennes
hier entre 340 huile et huit cent mille
personnes selon les organisateurs ou
selon la police ont refusé à le mariage
et l'adoption pour les couples du même
sexe en ligne avec nous béatrice bourges
bonsoir vous étiez candidate aux
élections législatives dans les yvelines
sur versailles le l'an dernier candidate
divers droite aujourd'hui vous êtes
porte parole du collectif pour l'enfant
et porte parole de la manif pour tous le
gouvernement qui reste ferme toujours ce
soir la loi sera présenté au palace
semblait au parlement quelle est votre
réaction votre point de vue après la
mobilisation d'hier vraiment poings nus
c'est que je suis quand même extrêmement
étonné d'abord chez je tiens vraiment à
dire qu'on était plus d'un million
puisque quand on a annoncé huit formules
en fait encore des tas lyon n'était pas
d'arriver donc de source officielle on
était plus d'un million était plutôt un
million de son monde donc c'est
absolument exceptionnelles comme lors
des négociations alors un million deux
cent mille pour vous selon la préfecture
le chiffre était de 340 milliers pour
l'instant la préfecture n'a pas revu à
la hausse ses chiffres
on était face à une mobilisation quasi
sans précédent et ça tourne lui est ce
qui est très étonnant c'est que le
gouvernement reste ferme sur ses
positions
je me demande ce que ça cache meilleur
parce qu'un gouvernement qui se dit très
ouvert qui fait des états généraux sur
un peu tout kilic c'est un gouvernement
tout à fait démocratique de concertation
et c'est sur ce qui touche aux
fondements de la société parce que
qu'est-ce qui touche encore plus aux
fondements de la société que la famille
je ne sais pas et bien sûr ce sujet là
il reste arc-boutée sur des positions
malgré donc
des centaines de millions de personnes
qui défilent dans la rue dans le trophée
milliard et aujourd'hui concrètement
vous attendez points
vous attendez quoi du gouvernement a
premièrement qui nous reçoivent savons
pas quand même la moindre des choses
et puis et puis des diamants qui
s'intéressent un peu le on a été reçus
en quelques enfin on est dans en fait je
n'hésite pas à dire qu'on est dans un
déni de démocratie totale et je trouve
ça assez grave pour le pays des droits
de l'homme soit disant qui s'appelle la
france
on est dans un déni de démocratie donc
moi je suis havrais estomaqué pas
vraiment très choquée parce que je
comprends très bien qu'on pense pas
comme nous et en revanche le
gouvernement fait comme s'il n'y avait
pas d'opposition à ce projet noir mais
au delà du fait d'être reçus ou non par
le gouvernement vous attendez quoi un
retrait de ce projet de loi le recours à
un référendum pour que le peuple se
plaignent mieux le retrait du projet
noie met au monde que la démocratie sur
les secteurs et que donc ce projet de
loi soit en effet soumis à référendum
comme il est tout à fait possible grâce
à l'article 11 ou le président de la
république sur tout ce qui concerne les
affaires économiques sociales et là on y
est bien et environnementales que
soumettre un texte à référendum
donc on est en plein dedans il ya des
tas de gens qui sont descendus dans la
rue on va demander un référendum en
effet et on va faire tout pour l'obtenir
parce que ce débat est un débat qui
appartient au peuple
donc on a l'impression que le pouvoir
confisqué
ce débat se confie ce que ces produits
noah alors que sa prose une loi qui ne
concerne pas seulement quelques-uns et
la société toute entière donc surtout
que le gouvernement ne se niche pas
voilà ils sont magnifiques manifester on
leur a fait plaisir est là maintenant le
soufflé va retomber
parce qu'en réalité le souffle et devra
monter de plus en plus et je prends
vraiment
je pense vraiment que le gouvernement a
tout à fait intérêt à dans cette période
économique et qui est extrêmement
compliqué pour lui à gérer à ne pas
faire de fracture sociale supplémentaire
donc à écouter tout le monde vous allez
appeler une nouvelle mobilisation et
nouvelles manifestations
peut-être peut-être peut-être peut-être
là on est on est quand même un peu on
est touchante des pixels donc succès à
les passionnés différence est sous le
choc du déni démocratique donc on était
dans notre dame assentiment à 2
milliards qui est un immense succès hier
quelques hommes se sont exprimés dans
une annexe p2 un esprit de baie de
cannes de sérénité de tranquillité
et puis de l'autre côté mais ces deux
murs fermé brac est bloqué et là on se
dit bon c'est quand même bizarre qu'est
ce que ça cache en fait derrière tout
forme est en train de se dire mais
qu'est ce que ça cache également
donc au final vous parler de cette
mobilisation on va y revenir justement
sur le déroulement de cette
manifestation vous l'avez dit les choses
se sont déroulées calmement pourtant on
a pu entendre quelques fois on a pu lire
également quelques témoignages quelques
dérapages peu traître vous l'avez dit
plus d'une fois vous en tant que porte
parole mais également d'autres du
mouvement il ne s'agissait pas d'une
manifestation homophobes contre les
homosexuels et pour autant quelques fois
il ya eu quelques quelques débordements
on a pu lire ici et là dans la presse
qu'il fallait le pénaliser
l'homosexualité par exemple un des
manifestants vous n'avez pas peur que ça
brouille aussi votre message après ça
fait partie de l'ensemble des gens qui
étaient dans la rue dimanche
non mais c'est pas notre manifestation
je savais bien d'ailleurs
donc en fait on est on est en été c'est
vrai
et on est même c'est même incroyable
qu'une manifestation ce soit cette
manifestation après car les autres
chacun fait ce qu'il veut
vous n'avez pas peur que ça brouille
ceci dit le message parce que au delà de
la mobilisation dans la rue ils sont
intelligents et je crois qu'il faut dire
arrêtez de prendre les gens pour des
pour souvent les gens qui n'ont pas de
réflexion ils sont capables de faire
pignon par un m
ils ont très bien vu et il était
d'ailleurs pour beaucoup dans l'ariège
ou à leurs valets peau et cetera et donc
après on torture et le récupérer mais ça
m'intéresse pas en réalité qui
m'intéresse moi vraiment et le débat de
fond et débats de fond c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait alors justement une
trimestre est ce que nous disions à la
fermer ou est-ce que autre que
tranquillement et sereinement guiborat
finalement c'est justement sur ce projet
de loi il ya eu un geste en tout cas de
la part du gouvernement c'était le
retrait de l'amendement prévu en tout
cas par les socialistes lors de la
présentation du projet de loi sur la pma
la procréation médicalement assistée qui
fera l'objet éventuellement d'une future
proposition de loi autour de la famille
là ce n'est pas suffisant vous voulez
véritablement aller plus loin d'abord il
ya un amendement qui sera déposée par le
parti socialiste mais que je sache le
parti socialiste on est encore une fois
on est en démocratie que les gars vont
déposer un amendement
ils l'ont dit clairement donc y aura
peut-être des socialistes qui vont le co
signé cet amendement donc
il y aura un amendement de contre aux
créations médicalement assistée et puis
ensuite fait reculer pour mieux sauter
puisque le gouvernement nous dit bernard
rappaz dans cette fois mais elle aura
dans trois mois
kossmann pesci mais on n'est plus le
même temps on n'est plus dans la même
loi c-6 bien même amendement qui sera
déposé dans un autre projet noah donc au
total de côte il parvient même que ce
soit maintenant ou dans trois mois c'est
la même chose et après la pma aux non
d'égalité c'est la gpa sinon on ne dit
pas que ce projet nous allécher au nom
d'égalité parce que s'il n'y a pas
égalité hommes et quand les femmes en
tant que couple alors moi je fais et à
l'inégalité dans le sang dit que les
femmes à couple femme femme peut avoir
un enfant et ça se fera soit maintenant
soit dans trois mois et à ce moment là
mais il est vrai que je voulais vous de
vous annoncer afrique quand on a été
reçus par erwann binet erwan daniel
danis non non non il y aura pas de gta
parce que et ça c'est un scoop que les
couples ne sont pas égaux aux couples
femmes femmes
alors là où on a laissé comme nos
enfants si je puis dire
c'était absolument spectaculaire c'est à
dire que considéré qu'un couple y vienne
était pas égal à un couple de l'est mais
il n'est pas là pour vous répondre sur
ce plateau c'est l'information que vous
nous donnez vous nous présenter comme un
scoop mais il n'est pas la personne sur
ce plateau pour confirmer ou non en tout
cas merci béatrice bourges d'avoir été
avec nous pour revenir sur cette
mobilisation de ce week end je rappelle
que vous êtes la porte parole de la
manif pour tous qui a réuni vous nous le
disent y ait un peu plus d'un million de
personnes selon les organisateurs 340000
toujours selon la préfecture et puis
éventuellement d'autres mobilisations
sont à venir
suite au gouvernement qui reste pour
l'instant fermé et sur ses positions
proposition de loi qui sera déposé le 29
janvier devant l'assemblée nationale
merci béatrice bourges
je vous en remercie béatrice bourges
elle nous restons donc sur ce sujet du
mariage gay avec à présent une interview
d'aurore verger et militante responsable
ump dans le département proche de
françois fillon de valérie pécresse
également elle a publié ce week-end sur
le site internet du nouvel obs une
tribune en faveur du projet de loi vont
d'écouter ses explications voici déjà sa
réaction la manifestation est dit
heures dimanche on s'attendait à une
très forte mobilisation contre le projet
de loi
je pense que ça en fait quand même nous
demande une demande de beda et un
problème quant à la méthode qui a été
choisi par françois hollande et par le
gouvernement qui d'un côté se sont pas
passées très rapidement sur le projet de
noir puisqu'ils n'ont pas présenté
il aurait pu présenter tout de suite
après leur élection j'ai donc fait le
choix elle ne présentait plus tard sans
pour autant ouvrir le débat et fait
paradoxal et je pense que cette méthode
l'un qui a été dénoncé et probablement
aussi le mépris du gouvernement à
l'égard d'un certain nombre d'opposants
qui n'a pas aidé à la bête qui n'ont pas
changé leur calendrier qui va changer le
projet du nord ce qui est sûr qu il
pense que la méthode qui a été choisie
n'était pas la bonne et qu'elle est
finalement contesté et par les opposants
et par les participants au projet doit
henri guaino député ump des yvelines de
la 3e circonscription étaient présents
lors de la manif pour tous aurore bergé
elle se rendra à la marche prévue le 27
janvier par les partisans du projet de
loi militante ump mais favorable à la
réforme elle a jeté un pavé dans la mare
ce week end en publiant une longue
tribune sur le site internet du nouvel
obs pour expliquer son point de vue
l'objectif en clientèle krivine qui
avait justement montré qu'elle restait
des points de vue qui peuvent être
exprimées au sein de l'ump
moi je suis lentement je les lui il
favorable au projet doit en tout cas je
ne me voyais pas continuer à être
contrée amis opposés et je pense au type
que la mobilisation importante
d'arguments qui ont été avancées contre
le projet de loi ont particulièrement
merci quand on entend un nombre de
personnes et aussi en réaction à celle
que j'ai vu le propositions honnêtement
je n'ai eu aucun retour négatif donc un
cadre responsable ou élue elle est bien
au contraire
j'ai eu des retours positifs un de ceux
qui peuvent être opposés au projet de
loi mais qui comprenait toutes façons ma
position et même ce prêt à libérer
quelque part la parole au sein de l'ump
d'enfants dont deux cadres des du lot
peau des militants sans clément
d'électeurs de droite qui était heureux
avec une autre position puisse et
dignité et puis se faire entendre
dessus pour le projet de loi le projet
de loi sur le mariage et l'adoption
les deux ensemble la fin et partisans et
opposants se rejoignent là dessus tu
n'ouvres le droit au mariage ouvre le
droit à l'adoption
donc je suis favorable à ce type de
sujet sur la procréation médicalement a
coûté des points faibles en projet de
loi j'ai l'impression que les
parlementaires socialistes ont revenu
aussi sur l'arrivée de te poser un
amendement sur le sujet je suis plutôt
défavorable et je vais gestation pour
autrui elle est clairement très
défavorable au nom notamment du droit
des femmes
voilà pour le point de vue d'aurore
berger militante ump des yvelines
installé à manier les hameaux elle sera
donc dans ce cortège le 27 janvier en
faveur du projet de loi deux jours avant
l'examen du texte à l'assemblée
nationale le
vernement qui se montrent unis sur cette
question voici à présent le point de vue
de benoît hamon ministre socialiste et
lui de la 11e circonscription également
l'an dernier c'était il ya quelques
jours à notre micro
moi j'y suis favorable je suis favorable
même si je ne suis pas favorable à ce
qui est en inscrivent dans ce texte de
loi
la procréation médicalement assistée
pour les couples de lesbiennes je pense
que ce n'est pas dans ce texte que
qu'une telle disposition doit être prise
mais bon des français vont manifester
c'est pas moi qui ai battu le pavé
souvent qui vais leur reprocher
d'exprimer leurs convictions moi ce que
je souhaite c'est que ça se fasse dans
le respect de la position de l'autre
dans un climat de tolérance avec le
refus ou la mise à l'écart de tous les
extrémistes et notamment ceux qui
pourraient être tentés par un discours
homophobes mais je sais voilà je sais
aussi que
il y aura des familles qui des deux
hommes et des femmes qui manifestent
euros le 13 janvier et pour lequel avec
lesquels je ne suis pas d'accord mais
bon démocratie on a le droit d'aller
exprimer ses idées y compris dans la rue
si je rajoute que pour les français
parce que je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de
français catholiques s'en inquiète en
même temps pour ceux qui souhaitent se
marier dans une église et un mariage
confessionnelles ils conserveront
l'intégrité du mariage tel qu'il
existait auparavant il ne s'agit là que
du mariage civil républicain la
dimension spirituelle on peut la
conserver dans son intégrité
que ce soit dans une église une mosquée
ou une synagogue ou ailleurs et nous lui
avons également posé cette question
faut-il parler de ce mariage pour tous
du mariage gay dans les écoles après la
polémique suscitée ces derniers jours
après le rappel à l'ordre de vincent
peillon le ministre de l'éducation
responsables des établissements
catholiques il a voulu déterré aucune
hache de guerre il dit que l'enceinte de
l'école faut faire attention débat
d'actualité qui sont des baraques
d'actualité qui si les débats sont
malmenés dans l'enceinte de l'école
peuvent bouleverser des enfants des
jeunes et c'est en ce sens que nous
appelons à la neutralité l'école
publique comme l'école privée catholique
sous contrat avec l'état dans
un débat comme celui là c'était le sens
de son rappel à la loi en quelque sorte
et pour en savoir plus sur ce dossier du
mariage pour tous rendez vous sur notre
site internet où vous retrouverez notre
page spéciale avec l'ensemble des
interviews des débats et des reportages
au rappel après la mobilisation jugée
inconsistante par le gouvernement que le
planning ne change pas présentation de
la réforme le 29 janvier à l'assemblée
nationale